all right Oliver
Oliver uh where are you from where'd you
grow up
um I grew up in Hammond Indiana uh
I believe I was born in Munster I'm not
really sure but I was adopted at Birth
and raised by My adoptive parents
nah how'd you describe your childhood in
general
if I had one word I would say chaotic
um
my father was a really bad alcoholic
when I was a little kid and my mother
didn't
really help the situation you know she
she never hurt me you know she tried her
best but at the same time she has her
own trauma and
kind of enforced his patterns I remember
a lot of the time of a fair bit of times
we've had to go to a hotel at night
because he was making a mess and I often
was the one
left cleaning up after him uh the messes
on the floor and
listening to all the yelling and crap
you know never physically what kind of
mess mess like
um knocking Furniture over food left all
over the floor
um cigarette butts everywhere piss in
the bathroom stuff like that because he
couldn't even see straight when he was
this bad wow
and you uh you endure this for how long
um it's still ongoing it's not nearly as
bad as it used to be I I don't even like
to call him dad honestly but credit
where credit's due he's gotten a lot
better with drinking
but it was really bad up until oh gosh
maybe like
I want to say eight or nine years olds
and that's all it took to give me a
incredible fear of alcohol at all
what do you know anything about his
childhood I know he was abused by his
father all I know is that his dad broke
his arm when he was a kid
um and I I do feel bad for him you know
in that sense but
something I don't give and pity for is
just the fact that he's let it
completely take over his life he's never
tried to improve his mental state and
therapy nothing like that no and it's uh
the very obvious he's very narcissistic
claims everything doesn't listen to
anybody else it has to be his way or no
way
was there any physical abuse or any
abuse like that
um ironically when it comes to him he
was the one that told my mom not to
spank me but he and I have gotten in a
couple physical fights before usually
provoked or I provoked it
um
very recently a couple months last year
I guess uh he was drunk passed out on
the couch and I was pissed off because I
grew up with this I was tired of it and
um
I was making soup and just talking about
how much of a mess there was in the
kitchen and I guess he wasn't completely
asleep
so he got up started cussing and he was
washing the dishes while talking to me
and I just said you know please don't
talk to me when you were in this state I
don't want to hear it and that must have
really pissed him off because he like
put his hand shove me up against the
wall and started screaming in my face
that uh you know I'm just a [__]
child I don't my opinions don't matter
he can do whatever the [__] he wants
stuff like that and that I'm just a
useless piece of [__] basically
it's mainly been verbal abuse yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
um High School I
I think that's when a lot of my mental
problems started really showing at least
the more violent aspects of them because
when I was in elementary school
um
I was always the big bully or the
bullied I mean the victim of the big
bullies and
um
that really left an impact on me like it
was physical sexual verbal and
um
I would wake up every morning with
intense panic attacks but we didn't know
what they were until I was about 11 so I
would often be told I was faking it and
I think that definitely took a toll on
my self-confidence alongside the
bullying at school
but in high school
um
I went to a private school
it was in the basement of a church
actually and there was just including me
there's four kids
um
and I think it was nice you know but
I could tell that I didn't really fit in
because a lot of them were like fanatic
anime fans and I wanted nothing to do
with it because of trauma I had
experienced in the past with
people who are addicted to that [__] and
eventually just got to a point where I
was
so emotionally unstable I had to just
start doing complete homeschooling I
couldn't leave the house anymore for
months
do you have friends
what age range well like teenage years
not really
um I I guess I could consider one or two
of the schoolmates of my friends but
I can kind of tell they were just
putting up with me you know only one of
them was a true friend uh but I don't
talk to him anymore
in elementary
um
I maybe had
one real life close friends named well I
don't maybe I shouldn't say names but
she was very special to me I talked to
her every single day
um we went to Six Flags together but
then after fifth grade you know when we
moved on to high school she just kind of
abandoned me she never called me anymore
didn't want anything to do with me and
just grew out of me and I think that
is really what started to trigger my
fear of Abandonment in everybody
now 20 you're 20. so you're still very
young yes what are you doing are you
working are you
um I had a job at Pizza Hut for like a
week but it was too over stimulating
like all the smells and the sounds and
stuff I was a delivery driver
um so I had to quit but
the people there were very nice couldn't
have been blessed to have a nicer
manager he was very understanding
but
as of right now I just do ubereats
because that's all I can really afford
to do
um
when it comes to my panic attacks at
least
but hopefully one day I'd like to be an
art therapist hmm
if you've seen a therapist about your
yes anxiety and all this panic attacks
yeah
his name is uh Andrew he's a really
really great guy are there medications
that you're taking or anything like that
yeah uh guanfacine I think that's for
blood pressure
uh venlafaxine for depression though I
don't know if that's really helped
um
we're trying to get me on mood
stabilizers because even though I it was
really obvious I had borderline for a
long time now
um
they never officially diagnosed me until
early last year so I haven't had the
chance to
see a psychiatrist about that yeah so
your borderline personality disorder as
well I have God I can probably list it
on my hands borderline chronic or not
chronic complex post-traumatic stress
disorder generalized anxiety disorder
panic disorder
autism spectrum disorder
ADHD and what what's that last thing
there it is my ADHD I can't even [__]
remember
um major depression and avoidant
restrictive food intake disorder very
unknown eating disorder
do you think about all these or most of
them are
attributable to your your father
yes his behavior and the uh the sort of
surroundings I was in an elementary yeah
because I I still have nightmares just
about every night of my elementary
school
what was going on in elementary that was
so tough
I was everybody's victim uh I don't know
if it had to do with a racial aspect
because I I kind of have the Michael
Jackson treatment where I used to be
really really dark when I was younger
um
but I was the fat kid I was the weirdo
because I never fit in I had my own
little special interest and would do my
own thing but you know uh name calling
stealing things out of my desk pushing
me beating me up if they had the chance
um
really just shaming me for anything and
everything they could and because you
were vulnerable or weaker or something
yeah physically and mentally you could
take on that they could sense that and
take on it and
um there was one year I believe in
uh first or second grade there was a kid
who we were watching a movie Saw the
lights were off and he wanted to be my
boyfriend at the time and
um
uh he basically raped me long story
short I mean he
he shot he forced his hands into my
pants and started you know rubbing up on
me grabbed my hand made me rub him I
didn't know what the hell was going on
but I think because of that early sexual
experience it um led me down a path
of just terrible
sexual acts upon myself and others that
I'm I still hold a lot of guilt for
what kind of I mean so you're straighter
you're gay or uh well I was born a
female so I used to just be straight I
thought I was bisexual for the longest
time because of
um online my weird fetish will probably
eventually talk about in the community
is mainly based around female figures so
I didn't have a lot
of other way to tell if I liked guys but
as soon as I transitioned to mail
um
I kind of real I when I was doing my
therapy work and self-reflection I
realized that no I don't like women I
just um I thought I did but it was
because I was just sexually groomed at
such a young age surrounded by all these
pictures and videos of women that that's
you know that's all I had at the time
I don't know if that makes sense or not
you you presented as very male now uh
thank you I appreciate it are you taking
hormones and things like that yes I am
then that deepens your voice and gives
you a little facial hair and stuff like
that yeah it's I just uh surpassed a
year actually
and you're happier
this way much happier yes
I would like to get a maybe voice
surgery someday and still iffy about my
breasts because I've always been very
flat chested anyway so bottom surgery is
a whole different ballpark though I
would think especially for a female a
born female person yeah
interesting to do that
can I ask what do they do
um it depends on what you are looking
for me personally I'm along the
non-binary Spectrum so
I don't really feel comfortable getting
rid of my vagina I don't mind it doesn't
really bother me and my identity
but I would like to create a sort of
phallus with the clitoris and that's
something that's been a lot of a lot of
non-binary people have been doing now
I can't remember the exact name of that
but that's what I'm after specifically
and you also told me before we
met that you are into
is it vorophilia yes that's the name of
the fetish what is that
voraphilia I wish I had the wiki
definition on me
um but basically it is a weird-ass
fetish where somebody is sexually
aroused by either eating people or being
eaten not in a cannibalistic way like
chewing and cooking all that crap
honestly that makes me sick to think
about it's very cartoonish
like an old Tom and Jerry skit or you
know cartoon snakes eating people it's
just swallowing really and uh
[__] I think I've been into it since I
was like five years old
so you'll swallow what exactly
well I it's a fantasy so it's you know
it's not physically possible I can't do
it it's just imagination really you
imagine like eating like what fingers or
what no just the whole ass people really
that's what it is yeah it's very obscure
it's very weird and I I honestly make
fun of it as much as I am as I get off
to it because it's so silly
um but it's very huge on the internet
which is why I was surprised you didn't
have any
um videos about it in your playlist I
might know yeah and that's fine honestly
I was more excited to talk about that
because it's just something I've been
very passionate about since I was a
little kid
as stupid as it is and I feel like it's
very misunderstood for good reason
but yeah
any questions you have I'm not sure do
you have any theories on how you came
about having that fetish yes
um
when I was an infant
um I used to have really bad night
terrors and my mother would take me in
the bathroom
and she'd set a warm bath for me and she
would lay my ear on her stomach and I
think as I grew up
that alongside all the cartoons I would
watch with just characters being eaten
and [__] my brain kind of associated the
sound like the internal body sounds as a
comforting thing the warmth and just
specifically its stomach sounds really
that get me and I think it's because of
that not to blame my mom or anything
that wasn't her intention obviously but
um that alongside internet I was on the
internet way too young stumbled across
it way too young
and I'll never forget the face
and my grandma made when she saw me
watching a video like a 3D animation on
the computer when I was like
six years old
I feel so bad for her for having to
witness that [__]
if you were watching what exactly
animations
um like or comic books slideshows that
people have drawn on this subject
and you so your romantic life do you do
you have do you have relation romantic
relationships
I do and unfortunately it's been I think
that's one of the hardest parts about my
life just because of how my borderline
affects me it's not just platonic or
familial relationships that [__] me up
it's romantic ones as well I'm currently
in a relationship but I'm I'm scared to
say that because I have such a high fear
of Abandonment [__] things up that I
don't know how long that's gonna last
it's
there's a lot of things I've done in my
past in relationships that I've
I've promised myself I would never do
again
in your borderline personality disorder
might must make it especially difficult
right yes
um mainly with you know controlling my
emotions uh way before I was diagnosed
I think the signs really started showing
when I was about 11 years old
um because that's when I would become
more verbally violent towards others and
show a lot of maladaptive behaviors of
attention seeking because I was so
lonely and hated so much self-loathing
um
my first ever relationship with a guy
I was I was an abuser in every sense of
the word and well maybe not sexual but
um physical and emotional abuse verbal
abuse and uh
it's it's hard because he says he
forgives me you know we're still in
contact but I I just
I can't let go of
everything that I've done
if I could take it back I would give up
anything to do so
what is your relationship like now with
your
with your family
um
well I still don't have a real
relationship with My adoptive father
adoptive mother I'm very close to her
um you're closer to your mom yes she she
and I do have some problems mainly
with codependency and being raised in a
situation where I was very heavily
parentified having to take care of
myself and take care of her when you
know he was really drunk
um
but we've gotten a little bit better but
now she tends to use my BPD as an excuse
to just call me not verbatim but
essentially just call me an [__] and
that's why all my relationships are
ruined
she's
very flippant I can never tell
when she's gonna be nicer when she's
gonna be in a mood
did you feel loved when you're a kid
no
um
at the most I could say I was very
financially taken care of I was very
spoiled I had I got everything I wanted
but
there's always a difference between uh
you know love Financial love and true
emotional connection and I never got
that with
my father my mom
I would say was more loving towards me
but then again like I said it's just she
flips on a dime
at times
what emotions do you deal with other
than depression
anxiety mainly anger anger is more than
anything I cannot control my anger if
anything makes me mad just getting here
parking outside was terrible because
there was some [__] that decided to
park so close to the left to the only
remaining parking space that I had to
squeeze my body outside the door and I
was so pissed off
and it's it's the little things it can
be as much as people breathing too loud
people making sounds and I think that
comes from the autism being very easily
um sensitive to
well everything but it triggers anger in
me which of your
mental conditions is the most
powerful I guess in your life is it
autism or is it borderline or it's hard
to say in uh just like as an as a
general
label I um I mean
different aspects so when it comes to
public speaking and working definitely
my generalized anxiety
borderline is the worst when it comes to
relationships and emotions
autism doesn't really
affect me too bad outside of just not
understanding social cues and the
oversensitivity to sound smells textures
and all that sort of stuff
but um I actually uh
I was one of the very many groups of
people who were female at Birth since
autism shows up differently in
biological women I was under the radar I
only got diagnosed with autism around
in May I think of this year yes I
suggest very recently
as well as the ADHD on the side
I guess though if I had to say as a
general overview of my life that my
cptsd is the worst because I constantly
get
emotional flashbacks all the time and uh
honestly I cannot I literally cannot
remember the last time that I didn't
have some at least one terrible
nightmare
every night
about drama
do you exhibit like self-destructive
behaviors yes I've had them ever since I
was a little child
um
when I was really young under the age of
10 years old I would try to either I
would binge eat or I would starve myself
depending on
whatever the situation was I always
wanted to punish myself because I always
grew up
knowing or being told basically that I
was the burden I make things worse so I
I've always self-harmed and when I was
maybe around nine nine or ten
um real cringe [__] looking back on it
but I was so desperate to seek help that
I didn't know how to get that I remember
taking silly scissors you know like that
they give kids and using that to cut
myself and send videos to my friends
because I didn't know how to
I never knew or never was taught how to
express my emotions in a healthy way and
I mean I'm glad they called me out at
the time they basically just told me you
know I don't want to see that [__] get
the [__] out of here get away from me I
don't blame them
but nowadays it's mainly hitting
um
but one time it was very very bad my
first breakup
uh I think I still have the scars
actually because I
I went outside
I was crying begging for him not to
leave because it was long distance
cutting myself on the road
I think I pissed myself because I was
such a [__] mess I just did not care
and um
put
my all my antidepressants in my mouth I
was ready to swallow them but I just I
couldn't because I was too scared
because I was born or I was raised to be
a bible thumper so you know no matter
what I believe now I'm always going to
have that fear of going to hell and uh
and I spit them out but it was kind of
too late at that point because then the
ambulance came over and I was sent to
the hospital
what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear
um
myself
I'm a monster at least I can be and
I'm really doing everything in my power
to prove not only to myself but to
the world that
borderline isn't a death sentence it
doesn't have to be people can recover
but it's such a misunderstood
disorder because of all the destructive
things that we do to ourselves and other
people
and that's one of the main reasons I'd
like to be a therapist someday because
I want to give people
the love and support and the ear
the shoulder the cry on that I never got
when I was younger
what would you say the most important
thing you've learned in your 20 years
the most important oh man
that's that's hard to say I guess you've
been through so much yeah I I haven't
even gotten the half of the [__] I've
been through
um
maybe it's my hyper vigilance my pdsd
telling me this but
I think the most important thing is that
nobody can ever fully be trusted
nobody's safe
ever
you can be as close as this to somebody
it could be conjoined twins level in
close but
there's always going to be people who
will stab you in the back and you never
know
when it's going to happen
I just recently had to experience that
again with some lifelong friends and it
only reinforced that belief
all right Oliver thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem very
interesting
thank you situation you're in I
appreciate you having me I
figured I
didn't I figured I wasn't good enough
didn't have enough trauma or whatever to
no it's not a contest thank you very
much no problem